[Music]
it's a battle of the revenge bods I'm
quite excited it's so fight flip or flop
stars Tarek and Christina el Moussa have
played it cool since announcing their
divorce in December but there seems to
be a bit of competition when it comes to
the Djinn both reality stars have never
looked more fit I'm doing really good
I'm in a really good place Christina's
body looks more than good these days
check out the 33 year old during a
recent bikini photo shoot those ABS do
not lie
I found yoga and yoga psyche really
helped me relieve a lot of stress and
really helped me think like you know
that I have control over my emotions and
it's a really fine piece as for Tariq
his fitness game is just as strong check
out the buff 35 year old putting in work
at the gym he and his trainer Quentin
Tucker have been sharing tons of workout
videos on social media and clearly all
that hard work is paying off here's
Tariq in Costa Rica earlier this week
looking super cut it works out great
which el Moussa revenge bod gets your
vote Cristina's or tarick's tweet us
your pic at 80 now
[Music]
you